recognizing the importance of mental
health among law enforcement that was
the goal of a special event held tonight
at the Mob Museum current and retired
officers joining a psychotherapist to
talk about the trauma our First
Responders face and also ways to get
them the help they need Sasha Loftus was
there and she joins us live from
downtown with more
Denise and Brian studies show police
officers are more likely to die by
Suicide and then than in the line of
duty those who are here tonight say
events like this are an important first
step to acknowledge the the toll that
trauma can take
the thoughts come back up Nevada State
Police Sergeant Travis smacka shares the
struggles he still faces after
responding to the one October shooting
people are losing their lives over
Mental Health
people being triage parking lot he's one
of several who participated in this
panel at the Mob Museum touching on the
mental and emotional challenges law
enforcement here in Las Vegas face every
day we have to change this Macho
stoicism that we've always had where we
keep these things buried suicide rates
post-traumatic stress disorder and
substance abuse were all discussed as
officers deal with death and destruction
every single day people can have an
awareness of the symptoms Dr Trudy
Gilbert Elliott says a lot of times
those symptoms present themselves
differently than people might expect
over a course of many many years of
being exposed to trauma after trauma
after trauma their brain begins to Tire
in that process that's why she
encourages First Responders to ask for
help when they need it no matter how
hard things may seem just as long as you
you get the treatment you need you can
still be very successful
now tonight they also touched on Clark
County Sheriff Kevin mcmahill's efforts
to create a wellness Bureau for metro
police officers to help treat those with
PTSD or other mental health issues
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now